we have a DVD that the Kim's accompany
can people get that ever Oh some voodoo
doctor
oh really really I don't on Amazon you
could still buy it yeah so that was a
long time ago
Kim's a comedy you watch it if you want
me can Steve and Kevin Chou Oishi have
you talked to Kevin Shea I haven't
talked to Kevin for a bit I know he
opens for Ken oh I know that on the road
yeah okay good bye I love Kevin he's
great I haven't seen him forbidden
wonderful didn't you he pushed me I
forgot didn't some we get body slam that
day or he bought it we were here we were
there when he buddies let me write with
a photo shoot yeah I remember double leg
takedown and he slammed me on my back
and I got knocked unconscious water oh I
was getting water to Tom and it came
back and no one was talking that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] that kid used to do what
the [ __ ] just happened
yeah there should be a TV show on the
road together what happened bodyslam
photo you jerking off in his backseat
was a lot of things so why did he body
though I don't know a lot it you don't
know know he especially out of everyone
that that was involved in that [ __ ]
thing okay
has the deepest seated resentment cuz
he's come up to me before that guy and I
don't care if I talk about him cuz he's
done this [ __ ] okay you know I was at
the Irvine improv okay with you know
Frank I'm sitting there you know eating
without eating but like it friends
hanging out yeah
and he's walked up to him ago hey what
does it feel like being a complete loser
and Ken is a big star and you're nothing
no yeah so one time I walked her to him
in the showroom he was drunk and I go
hey um I know you've done that twice now
yeah don't ever do that again you know
pushed me in the showroom he shoved me
away oh and I follow him outside right
and I'm like come here where you going
let's talk it out either [ __ ] you you
know I need left and that's the last
time I've seen him I saw him one time at
the 6th Street Cafe blue I was eating at
the Sun on bangs I don't know yeah and
he walked out with PK how did that bar
yeah and Ken pikas come over I go no cuz
that fog
and then and then Kevin Shea goes come
here let's talk it out now like a [ __ ]
you anyway ski burn everybody got the
amazing Jonathan documentary follow us
keep brutalize and check it all out
download download all right we'll be
back with some house key